and here's Billy Gardell do you know
Jonas Billy's going on me Billy how do
you do know how are you no I wasn't nice
to meet you man
of course Billy Gardell why you got a
new show coming in how do you say this
I'm Bob Hart's Abba Shola have a
shoulder you got that right yeah I had
no idea how this is happening I have a
horseshoe in my ass man we're gonna push
me out in the field let me be the medi
uncle or to wacky neighbor for the rest
of my career
yeah somehow you're back on the bus on
the sides of buses did you guys end it
or because bullets start doing movies
she was unbearable to work with we all
wanted to stay but there was
negotiations between CBS and Warner
Brothers and I don't think they could
settle on what they wanted to do so they
just said you know we got our 127 we're
in syndication we're gonna let it go we
would I think stayed we would I know she
wanted to stay and I think we could have
probably done another three years but
you know it's a scary thing I mean just
to be picked up for six years as I catch
any unicorns it's amazing and plus if
you're in syndication the money is
piling or I'm not panicking like you
know it's you know what's funny is you
can't ever [ __ ] about getting residuals
like that but if that had been a SAG
deal I'd be done working but in the
moment like when that's over after six
years is there this sort of like oh my
god this was this is my lifestyle what
am I gonna do next
um you know no because I'm married for
18 years and my wife was very smart with
the money she gave me 500 bucks cash
yeah we have a house my kid has a
college fund that she was really you got
500 bucks yeah in trouble with that
right if I had gone through that by
myself it would have been over and I
would have had like a hot air balloon
and a dolphin by the way here's what a
phony I am when you said if it was an
after deal a sag deal would've been
better it was after I went okay like I
knew you know I have no idea why I sighs
yeah what didn't bet here's the deal
sag and
Big Bang Theory are the last kids that
got that ride this is gonna this by the
conversation by the way is gonna help
Jim a lot no we're familiarizing it with
show business nobody here knew anything
about this
yeah sag when you go through syndication
with sag and it goes into syndication
the first year runs in syndication you
would get 80% of your original paycheck
Wow Wow
$50,000 in episode say you're gonna get
$38,000 in a residual per episode for
the first year just to sit at home
second year mailbox money yeah and your
goes down to 60 then 40 then 20 then 10
then it goes away
so you got five years of cake just
coming to the hell but you don't get
paid forever on that no oh
big money up front honey when it was sag
and then when it turned to after and
they combined the unions you know our
unions suck because we never you know
the corporations and production
companies hire lawyers you know we hire
a guy that guest-starred on [ __ ]
Magnum we wonder why we're losing money
but when it went to after all you get in
your residuals is what a guest star
would get as a residual and it ticks
down from there so Wow you still can't
comply I mean I got buddies in
Pittsburgh that are cops and breaking
pipes and if it was sag it would be so
Seinfeld got a sag deal oh okay well he
that and that big ownership deal you
know him and Larry David created that
show I didn't great anything oh you did
you audition for it you got I auditioned
for for Chuck Lorre at the that was the
last audition I had for the last pilot
season I was gonna be in LA and somehow
was a Hail Mary into the end zone and
he's been kind enough to say do you want
to do another show yeah this new shows
to check Laurie show as well right yeah
man I guess Chuck Lorre is one of those
guys in the business that if you if he
likes you yeah stay in the good graces
because he's been amazing to me on and
off stage he's been a good friend a
mentor he really took me under his wing
when we did Mike and Marcus I was
terrified man I was terrified to take
tech gig and he's been Ruger you
I was at a place when I got my Kamali
man where I was I think I was two years
away from not drinking I just quit
drinking for two years my marriage was
on the rocks and I just I couldn't get a
gig and I was really I was gonna go back
to Pittsburgh to go to Ranger Tom and
you know this guy's gets Berg they love
you um and he was gonna hire me as a
sidekick on the radio and I figured I
could go back there have a good life and
take care of my family and raise my son
I said I'm gonna ride out one more pilot
season and the last audition was Mike
and Molly and Wow Chuck called and said
look I want you to be this guy and I
said no and I did I wish I could have a
cool comic story for you where you go I
told them to wait man it wasn't that I
just I opened up with them and just
later in I said man I'm terrified I go I
got a little development deal with
Nickelodeon right now and I'm gonna use
that money to go home because I think
that projects no good so I'm just trying
to get out of here and he said well why
did you audition I said I was hoping for
a like a guest-starring part like later
down the line or something and he goes
well I want you to take a chance I'm
gonna I'm gonna surround you with a
great cast I mean you're not gonna have
to carry the water up the hill by
yourself and I want you to trust me this
other life in mind everything was but I
mean I was two years sober I was yeah
yeah nothing was working man and I
couldn't get a gig I was but I know a
hundred grand in debt and there's no
guarantee that's mike omalley things
don't work exactly and so to my wife's
credit again man I call I said I said to
chuck I said I want to tell my wife all
of this can I call you on Monday and he
said absolutely and he called me any
time gave me his number and he was
really good to me and still is to this
day and I called my wife and we were in
a bad place at the time man I said look
I go I go there's a chance that this
will take off and it'll be huge but I
said if it doesn't we have nothing we're
stuck in LA we're still broke and we're
still where we're at and even though we
were in a terrible place at the time and
now we're really great but at the time
we were in a terrible place like we're
on the brink a divorce she still looked
at me and said you've been waiting for
this phone call for 25 years
you have to do this so I give her all
the credit because the worst is amazing
yeah and that's an amazing that he's
stuck with you because if I got
I'm thinking I was like look I don't
think I can do that they're probably
like our thoughts exactly we were
concerned about that as well amazing the
Chuck did that and it's crazy that your
wife did that too I mean you know most
man huge especially where we were man I
have yeah I'd really I had really done
some damage to my marriage man with the
drinkin and I had a new baby at home and
and thank God I mean it all you know III
turned the corner and thank God I did
but she was strong enough to stay with
me and did it the world is hers as far
as I'm concerned from here forward when
you see like Melissa doing all these
films do you want to do any with her are
you like [ __ ] I would love to you know
um no I don't where were dear friends
and I think the reason we are is because
I never asked you to put me in your
movie I don't ever do that to her and so
I'm safe place for her I was kind of
like a big brother for her and and I
gotta tell you man I think I have the
perfect amount of success for me I I
don't know that I could handle all like
I I met with her a couple months ago we
were up here in New York together I was
doing a gig and she was filming a movie
and you know I walked down the street
pretty freely I don't have any you know
Lebanon then somebody go mike go mike
take a picture Mike it's Billy whatever
Mike but like she pulled up in an SUV
and there had to be security and there's
paparazzi immediately on her and I mean
it's really it's a lot to do that I
think about her to do that so she
handles it very well but that's that's
to me that would be it's a little too
much for my comfort and when you reach
that level to I feel like when Melissa
McCarthy was when she was on the show
when she was just kind of coming up
everybody loved her because she's so
funny she's lovely but the minute she
became super famous and everybody said
she was funny this wave comes in if
people being like she's not funny she
plays the same thing but and now you
have to deal with that right yeah I
think especially in the culture we live
in now well you know there's a
Springsteen song local hero and he says
first they make you the king then they
make you the Pope and then they bring
the rope and that's kind of the culture
we're in that you know yeah we're
rooting for you you had nothing you got
success congratulations and now you
you suck yeah so it's just a - you kill
the guy with the ball you know what I
mean that's what are you gonna do what
have you been doing for the last couple
years to this end it only ended 2016
it's like it's been off the air for a
long time I am I did I and you were kind
enough to have me on to help promote
that Sun Records show I did thank right
and I had a lot of fun that I played
Colonel Parker that's right and it was a
dramatic role nobody saw it he was very
excited about it was about Sun Records
Elvis and Jerry Lee Lewis and BB King
and all the things that went on in
Memphis and Stax Records and and and
then Sun Records got the bill and they
said we should probably go back to the
shows where people catch fish with their
arms because so they got canceled and
then I thought you know man I'm just
gonna sit back for a minute I'm gonna go
do my stand-up and try to write a new
hour and in tour a little bit and and
and I even have kind of cut that down
because my sons now 16 yeah and it's
hard enough to get time with him on the
weekends you know he's always gone in an
uber to his friends so I'm trying to
hold on to what little time I can get
with him before he goes off to college
as the first Gardel to ever make it to a
college and so I just kind of settled
into that and thought you know maybe
I'll guest star here guest star there
and then it's been a really bittersweet
year because a year ago this month my
dad passed from lung cancer and then
about a month later I find out I have
type 2 diabetes and then about two
months after that they strap me into a
sleep apnea machine so I'm just like
what the [ __ ] and you by the way apni
idea with I can't I can't I don't I'm
not on Twitter a lot but I saw that
thing you did and I was so with you this
if you want to pull it off your face
every 20 minutes yeah strapping into a
mig when you go to sleep yeah awful but
I have to do it can you sleep with have
you learned you've finally gotten to
where I've accepted it but it man it
took a lot of getting used to but it
dropped my blood pressure 25 points you
know it didn't happen he'll kill you man
it swells up your aorta it's all this
other crazy [ __ ] so I'm getting that
that and then Chuck calls me yeah he
goes I have an idea first show and I
think you're the guy that can be the
delivery system he calls you out of the
blue it's not an audition and this is
the first time that's ever happened Wow
I finish
listen I really think I need somebody
genuine with a big heart is what he said
and I think you're the guy for this and
he sent me the script and I got about
nine pages in and I said man I'm in I'm
100% in and I'm honored that you would
ask me again and and then he put this
thing together and he brought in
you know it's called Bob Hart's Abba
Shola it's a guy who owns compression
sock Factory which is amazing
how he got that I don't know but I
figured you know it's not X Olympic
swimmer so I could probably hit
compression socks yeah and then he wakes
up after a heart attack in his nurses
from Nigeria and she's a hard-working
immigrant who lives with her aunt and
uncle and has a son and she's trying to
make a better life for him and they're
completely different but sometimes when
you have a near-death experience it
imprints on you who's around you when
you come to and there's something about
her that he's taken by and it's just
about him trying to get her to give him
a chance and it's very sweet and very
kind which is this kind of stuff I kind
of gravitate to how do you say her name
side vilaça all-over flake oh wow how
long did it take you to get that I had
about three days I had to memorize
that's a real name and yes nashola is
who Xolos who she plays she's anguish
actress from Nigerian descent she's just
lovely and we've been up here don't
press we did stuff yesterday we got a
few things we got to do today and then
back to LA and you know we'll see if we
can find an audience for this thing how
often do you look at your life today and
like just think about how close you were
to having a completely different life if
that conversation would Chuck Lorre had
gone any sort of different way not even
in a negative way it just would have
been it would have made completely
different life you would have gone to
Pittsburgh you had done the radio thing
who knows well I will tell you that and
I'm not trying to sound like any Holy
Roller or anything but getting sober for
me mm-hmm
changed my perspective and it it I got
out of this is so trite but I got out of
my own way man
I got out of the way and when I was
finally brave enough to get out of the
way mm-hmm then I didn't have to control
everything I didn't have to worry about
the outcome I didn't have to have an
imaginary thing in my head you know they
say an alcoholic has a hundred endings
in his in his
head and not one of them is and it all
worked out find a way to turn that down
but when I got out of my way and let
things just go the way they were gonna
go and decided to go alright I'm gonna
accept whatever it is it just took off
it's hard to do that - it's really hard
tonight a stroll or try to control it
daily daily I'm crazy every morning man
I wake up every morning with you know
there's a calamity orchestra in my head
really to do my thing to get calm and
and the medicine I do yeah I think I can
get about three minutes okay I'm 11
years over I can only hold it together I
get too itchy like I literally yeah
you're gonna accept the itch and let it
pass let your thoughts come into your
head but don't serve them tea so I try
to do that then I try to be of service
during the day and I try to remember
that I'm just on borrowed time and I'm
very very blessed what are the guys that
you grew up with they do you still talk
to the guys you grew up what I do I did
I just had my 50th birthday man and I I
decided I wanted to fly in all the
people that kept me alive for the last
five decades so I got had buddies come
in that were friends from six years old
the high school friends the comics I
went on the road with the very beginning
and some people that I've met now in my
life recently and I just had a dinner
for them to say thank you you know they
really kept me alive through the ride
nice guy Billy I do just the opposite I
bring them out so they can praise me
[Laughter]
this morning I was like Jim what about
the guys you grew up with use like I
don't talk to ya that I'm very close
with that I still talk you talk to the
people that are you know just regular
working-class people that you grew up
with and try to explain to meditation
and and all this stuff just it's funny
my buddies are still pounding them back
in Pittsburgh you know why are you so
calm trying to get them a day man yeah
do something right and this Bible you
showed us we get promoted Monday
September 23rd at 8:30 like to have
critics reviewed it like you do you care
about that stuff I mean I don't
pay any heed if they say something good
thank you if they say something bad okay
you know I don't think you can you can't
control any of that and I learned that
through Mike and Molly all you can
control is do the best show you're gonna
do and then it's gonna happen or it's
not gonna happen I will say this though
um you know whenever they whenever
there's doubters I kind of like that
because they doubted us on Mike and
Molly - I did a show back in 2003 with
Craig Robinson and John Corbett called
lucky which I really loved is about
these three gambling degenerate robber
I'll call this absolutely and and it was
a great shows brilliant got nominated
for Best new series Emmy cancelled a
week later I did the CMT thing about Sun
Records critical darling cancelled made
episodes so I stored Dyson Rob Colin
would come with us indoors you yeah I
loved him too and we would literally
just sit outside and smoke and ruin well
has ever smoked more than Rob Rob smokes
more than dice yeah it's funny about the
critics because it's become a meme like
everybody's passing around the screen
grab of Rotten Tomatoes of Dave
Chappelle's news special all right
because it's like the critics are it's
like whatever it is 30% maybe 13
whatever it is it's less it's it's
terrible with the critics right and then
the audience scores 99% like it's you
know matters man it's critically going
violet they don't like the point of view
it's coming from or you know they just
haven't seen a special but Dave
Chappelle is probably one of them I mean
him and bird I think you know does it
yes those are the guys you know when I
started you've watched guys like that
and you go alright I may not get there
but I'm shooting for that so right I'm
not gonna get to that but that's what
I'm shooting right you know and I think
him and I actually like in Burr and
Chapelle - like Carlin and Pryor really
I think for our generation they've kind
of taken those man's you're shooting
much higher than I am
I just shoot ABAB Kelly I've always been
like two molecules off of being a great
comic to molecules off but you know what
it is you can identify it yeah and
you're like but I just don't know I
don't know how to get the more I the
more I am the more I act the more I the
less I want to do stand-up I'm really
finally getting this place where I am I
like acting better you get what anymore
if you went through I guess I get one
point where is like [ __ ] if this is a
great way to make a list well it's it's
I get this you know remember the
excitement you would get going to the
club just to do a spot yeah just like oh
I feel that way about acting and I don't
feel that way about stand-up anymore I
still like and respect stand up I'm a
fan a stand up I like watching you guys
who have way more balls and I do I love
watching you [ __ ] go out past the
edge you're insane
I watch and I go hope ate off for me too
you should ask the 80 people and Buffalo
this weekend you know it's they always
have to not as a whole but but there's
always a pocket of guys that has to stay
on that wall to make sure that they
don't move the wall in on us and I
admire guys that'll do that I'm a very
middle-of-the-road guy talk about my
family and I talk but that's who I am
yeah so I just stay with what I am but
I'm a big fan of stand-up and I
certainly respect it and I owe it
everything
stand-up is the reason I even got
noticed so I'm very also weird sometimes
the things that you're successful at you
realize they go this is this is the path
I should it's the path I should be on
anyway like this for instance the fact
that I just slapped my microphone out of
my face happenings like that keep your
name off the title of the show
yeah man it's it's weird like when
you're back in Pittsburgh what did you
want to do before stand-up I know we
have to wrap up with you there but what
did you want to do before standing up
you know I never from 9 years old on I
wanted to be a stand-up comic I watched
Johnny Carson with my grandmother on
Friday nights and I thought what is this
and I was enchanted by it my dad was a
big influence man my dad had all the
comedy records the button-down mind and
AMFM and you know priors uh Cheech and
Chong and and and I would listen to his
records when he wasn't around I was like
what are these guys doing man this is
the coolest thing I've ever heard in my
life and so I just always wanted to do
that I had a fantasy in high school
about becoming a cool English teacher
but then my grades were never going to
allow that to happen so one more
gemandsam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM attic